chers amis bonjour à toutes et à tous
merci encore pour votre participation
aux travaux d'hier qui a été je crois un
beau visage de ce que doit être notre
parti du 21e siècle
je voudrais saluer un certain nombre de
personnalités éminentes de notre
mouvement qui sont présents gérard
larcher le président du sénat que nous
pouvons applaudir question christian
jacob le président du groupe
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale et
tous les parlementaires nombreux qui
sont venus le dimanche pour être à nos
côtés pour cette dernière matinée de ce
conseil national alors en deux mots nous
allons dans le même esprit qui est
enchaîné la matinée avec à la fois des
interventions de responsables de notre
mouvement de la direction qui sont ici
et la matinée se terminera par le
discours de notre président nicolas
sarkozy qui vous présentera un texte
d'orientation celui de la direction qui
fera l'objet de débat comme ça a été
évoqué hier dans nos fédérations tout au
long de cette matinée
vous aurez la parole dans le même esprit
de ce qui a été réalisé hier
vous aurez la parole pour apporter votre
contribution pour réagir à des prises de
parole c'est cela le nouveau visage des
républicains c'est cela le parti
démocratique du 21e siècle que nous
voulons construire alors il me revient
d'ouvrir cette matinée et de partager
avec vous quelques réflexions sur ce que
doit être notre ligne politique puisque
c'est l'objet de ce conseil national mes
chers amis
j'ai une conviction je crois que si nous
voulons être le parti du réveil de la
france celui qui va redresser le pays
si nous voulons être ce parti du réveil
nous devons d'abord être le parti du
réel
regarder la réalité en face c'est ce qui
nous différencie à mon sens c'est une
véritable fracture avec la gauche avec
les socialistes
les socialistes vivent toujours dans le
rêve
ils vivent dans un monde virtuel
souvenez-vous françois hollande avait
promis de réenchanter le rêve depuis la
gauche déchantent et la france décroche
mais regarder le paysage politique au
delà des socialistes
monsieur montebourg et les verts sont
des adeptes de la démondialisation ou de
la décroissance
mélenchon et le pen eux ils veulent
sortir de l'euro au de l'europe
eh bien nous nous devons être le parti
de la vie réelle
être dans le réel c'est être capable de
tourner le dos à des utopies qui
conduisent dans l'impasse et même
parfois au désastre le réel
ce n'est pas la dora tion d'un passé
parfois fantasmer savez les nostalgiques
c'était mieux hier mais c'est pas non
plus l'adoration béate d'un futur
virtuel l'aurait elle ce n'est pas
l'auto flagellation dans laquelle trop
souvent certains aiment se complaire
mais ce n'est pas non plus l'auto
satisfaction
le parti en phase avec le réel
c'est d'abord un parti mes chers amis
qui comprend qu'ils acceptent les
transformations du monde et en explique
les opportunités aux français c'est cela
notre devoir à nous les républicains
nous avons un devoir de pédagogie
vis-à-vis de cela le monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est un monde ouvert la mondialisation
je suis désolé de le dire c'est pas une
option c'est pas un choix c'est un fait
elf impose à nous alors je comprends
qu'elle inquiète
je comprends qu'elle parfois elles
puissent créer des difficultés mais la
vérité c'est qu'elle peut constituer
pour notre pays
de formidables opportunités mes chers
amis le terrain de jeu du 21e siècle de
nos entreprises de notre nation c'est un
terrain mondiale
c'est ainsi c'est le monde dans lequel
nous sommes rentrés c'est celui de
l'interdépendance économique
ouvrons les yeux mes chers amis les
échanges mondiaux ont été triplé en
vingt ans l'investissement annuel
mondial dans la recherche a doublé en
dix ans en 15 ans le nombre de brevets a
été multiplié par 2,5
le nombre de multinationales est passée
de 7000 à 100 milles en moins de 40 ans
les fameux gaffard javel et google apple
facebook amazon ils ont moins de 40 ans
il pèse aujourd'hui l'équivalent de
nations de l'union européenne autour de
300 milliards de dollars
alors on peut le regretter ce monde on
peut le déplorer mais il est là c'est
cela le réel être dans le réel c'est
comprendre aussi que le monde
d'aujourd'hui est un monde instable un
monde volatiles jamais l'économie
mondiale n'aura connu un tel rythme de
crise de crise économique de crise
financière de crise mondiale on les
oublie même parfois telle elle se
succèdent dans quelques années la crise
argentine la crise asiatique la crise
russe la crise des subprimes la crise
grecque la crise de l'euro la crise du
rouble l'explosion du prix des matières
premières s'était à moins de 7 ans
l'affaissement du prix des matières
premières
c'est aujourd'hui tout peut arriver très
vite et les cartes sont en permanence
rebattues et bien la mondialisation
c'est le déplacement permanent des
barycentre économique
regardez la situation le brésil c'était
le nouvel eldorado
il ya encore cinq ans il est au bord de
la faillite l'allemagne c'était l'homme
malade de l'europe en 2000 ils ont tiré
la croissance européenne pendant 15 ans
et il pourrait à nouveau rencontrer des
difficultés économiques
regardez la situation des fameux bric
savez ces pays émergents qui devait
tirer la croissance mondiale
regardez ce qu'ils sont devenus avec un
pétrole à moins de 30 dollars le baril
le monde d'aujourd'hui enfin c'est un
monde où il est impossible de s'asseoir
sur une rente durable ou la prime doit
être au risque et la prime à
l'innovation et bien notre parti mes
chers amis il ne doit pas être le parti
de la rente et doit être le parti du
risque
il doit être le parti de l'innovation
regarder le monde en face
regardez le réel c'est aussi ne pas se
complaire dans la désignation hasardeuse
de bouc émissaire au premier rang duquel
et je tiens à la firme et l'europe sur
l'europe
je crois que nous avons une exigence de
crédibilité
sortons des vieux schémas qui parfois
nous ont divisées dans notre famille
politique entre les souverainistes d'un
côté les fédéralistes de l'autre ils
n'ont aucun sens aujourd'hui nous avons
changé d'époque
le monde d'aujourd'hui encore une fois
il est multipolaire c'est le monde des
pays continent face aux états unis face
à la chine face à l'inde
qui peut croire que nous pourrons
résister sans l'europe l'europe c'est le
terrain de jeu nos entreprises
l'europe c'est notre marché l'europe
c'est le premier pib mondial quand la
france pèse 1 % de la population
mondiale
alors je crois et c'est une conviction
profonde que nous devons être ouverts
avec méthode sans naïveté à plus
d'harmonisation européenne nicolas
l'avait initié lorsqu'il était président
de la république nous avions fait les
propositions de convergences économiques
fiscales budgétaires
vous savez la question aujourd'hui elle
est moins de taper sur les techno de
bruxelles que de prendre le pouvoir
politique en europe
moi j'en ai assez de voir monsieur
hollande montré du doigt l'europe pour
mieux masquer ses propres échecs
vous avez remarqué vous allez remarquer
s'est jamais de sa faute françois
hollande un camp c'est pas la faute à
sarko c'est la faute à l'euro c'est ça
françois hollande toujours un bouc
émissaire
oué oué le grand dessein de l'europe
aujourd'hui quelle est la vision de
françois hollande pour l'europe
quel est le chef d'état ou de
gouvernement
qui aujourd'hui a une ambition pour
l'europe
chers amis je crois que la place elle
est à prendre nicolas sarkozy a montré
lorsqu'il était président de l'union
européenne que la france pouvait parler
fortement en europe
regardez le monde du réel évitez les
boucs émissaires et nous pourrons
devenir le parti du réveil de la france
nous devons déverrouiller notre pays
nous avons souvent l'habitude de
critiquer les socialistes l'exécutif en
dix ans et non pas de cap
c'est vrai mais je crois qu'il faut
aller plus loin dans l'analyse
ce qui est plus grave ce n'est pas
l'absence de cap
c'est l'erreur d' analyse ce qui me
frappe chez françois hollande c'est
qu'ils continuent à résonner comme un
homme du 20e siècle
il attend que la croissance reparte
d'elle-même sous l'effet d'une reprise
venus d'ailleurs comme s'il suffisait
d'attendre la fin d'un cycle économique
comme c'était le cas après les crises
pétrolières des années 70 il n'a pas
compris que dans ce 21e siècle après la
crise l'économie givet non pas d'un
changement de cycle mais d'un véritable
changement de modèle qui exigeait un
changement de logiciel de notre part et
bien dans ce nouveau monde
à mon sens il y à trois maîtres mots
l'agilité la réactivité la compétitivité
la politique économique que nous devront
porter en 2017
elle devra être axée sur ces trois
principes agilité réactivité
compétitivité vous savez c'est très
concret ça et je vais vous donner
quelques exemples
la question aujourd'hui elle est plus de
savoir si c'est juste ou pas d'avoir un
impôt sur la fortune c'est pas la
question
la seule question qui vaille c'est qu'on
est les seuls en avoir un et que ça
baise la compétitivité française
c'est ça le sujet
sur la question de l'emploi
ça fait 40 ans qu'on protège ceux qui
sont dans le système
ceux qui ont un emploi on n'a toujours
pas compris que le problème c'était
parce ce qu'ils avaient un emploi c'est
ceux qui n'ont pas d'emploi
c'est toute la logique insider outsider
donc notre logique
notre démarche dans ce monde du 21e
siècle ça va être de s'occuper de ceux
qui n'ont pas d'emploi et de réfléchir
comment on peut leur trouver un emploi
quand pas comment on peut enfin penser à
des passerelles
c'est ça l'enjeu d'une nouvelle
politique économique c'est sympathique
de vouloir réformer le code du travail
mais quand j'entends certains dirigeants
politiques s'exprimer il s'adresse à la
vieille économie le monde du travail où
les salariés sont majoritaires
quel est notre réponse à ce nouveau
monde constitué d'auto-entrepreneur
constituée de travailleurs indépendants
nous pouvons plus avoir une règle
générale qui finalement ne supporte plus
les exceptions enfin changer de logiciel
ça signifie que quand l'investissement
dans la recherche et le développement
double tous les dix ans on ne tourne pas
le dos au progrès mes chers amis les
républicains doivent être le prat le
parti du principe d'innovation plus que
du principe de précaution
le parti du gaz de schiste le parti des
ogm
le parti d'epitech g7 intime conviction
alors mes chers amis je crois que c'est
parce que nous avons fait le bon constat
du monde dans lequel nous vivons que
nous pourrons apporter les bonnes
solutions
c'est comme cela que nous pourront
engendrer le réveil français
c'est pour cela que nous pourrons
redresser la france
comme je voulais dit guère plus que
jamais dans les mois qui viennent
la france aura besoin des républicains
merci